(playful music)
♪ It must be love ♪
- [Narrator] So how long have you two
been seeing each other?
- We've been in serious
committed relationship
for as long as I can remember.
We're basically relationship experts.
- [Narrator] How did you two meet?
(giggling)
- Well
- You tell them, Butter.
- No, you tell 'em.
- Okay. Well, it was really romantic.
(funky music)
- [Narrator] Wow, that sounds so romantic.
- Yeah, yeah, well we're soulmates.
- Soulmates.
- [Narrator] Wait, soulmtes?
I didn't know food had soulmates.
- Well, of course food has souls.
What do you think is happenin'
when you eat food and then you fart?
That's their souls escapin'.
- [Narrator] Okay. How do you
know that you're soulmates?
- Oh, that's easy.
There's so many way we know.
For one, we can tell each other anything.
And I mean, anything.
(bouncy music)
Um, you know I've never told anyone this.
- What?
- Nevermind, I'm too embarrassed.
- Just tell me.
- Oh, okay. Well someday,
I dream of becoming a cinnamon toast.
(buzzing)
- That's your biggest secret?
- I know, I'm very brave.
- I guess.
(bouncy music)
- Butter, I trust you so much.
I just gonna look through
your Facebook real fast, okay?
- Okay.
- No big deal. Just look around.
Who is this? What? Who is this?
Why is your arm around them?
Oh my God! Oh my goodness!
I'm freaking out!
I thought we were exclusive?
- That's my cousin.
- Oh, good. I knew that.
- We f***ed.
(bouncy music)
(buzzing)
(farting)
- Okay.
(bouncy music)
- Do you think I look okay in this?
- I think you look like the most
beautiful piece of avocado
toast in all of Brooklyn.
- I don't look too much like a hipster?
- No, I don't
- I'm just worried I look
like an overpriced brunch.
- I'd f*** that brunch.
(bouncy music)
- Oh, I don't know if I can do this.
- You'll be fine. You've got this!
- Um, I'm nervous.
- I believe in you!
- It's so freakin' hot.
- Just get in the damn toaster!
- Okay, okay, okay okay. I'm
getting in. I'm getting in.
Oh! Oh, this is really nice.
- Yeah, I told you.
- It's like warm. It's like a warm hug.
- [Butter] Oh Really?
- It burns so good.
(bouncy music)
- One more episode?
- Oh, I don't know. We've
already watched like 50.
My eyes are all dry.
- Yeah, you're right.
- Okay, one more episode.
I have to know what happens.
(bouncy music)
(moaning)
- [Toast] I can't believe
how much sex we have.
(moaning)
- [Butter] Oh! This is crazy!
- [Toast] Crazy? I bet
it's like this forever.
- [Butter] Yeah, yeah, yeah!
- [Toast] It'll never slow down.
- [Butter] Three times a day.
Sex, it's like this forever.
(buzzing)
(bouncing music)
- Our sense of humor
is like, super in sync.
Butter is hilarious.
- Wait, are you trying to
butter me up?
(giggling)
- Because you're made of
butter? That's hilarious!
That's the funniest thing I've ever heard.
- Yeah, it took me five hours.
- You're like Gallagher.
- Yeah, pretty much.
We're food, right?
(giggling)
(bouncy music)
- What if you die first?
- Oh yeah, I'm pretty sure I'd die first.
I fall a lot.
- But, I can't live without you.
- Fine. Well, let's just
die at the same time!
- Oh, that's a good idea.
But what if we just never die?
- And that's all you
need to know about love.
- Yeah. When you found
the one, you just know.
- Mmm hmm.
- Aaaah.
- Butter and Toast!
- [Toast] But not too much butter.
- [Butter] Hey, what are you
saying? What do you mean?
- [Toast] You know, cholesterol.
(bouncy music)